it is a huge honor to be here because as
Tom said I was I was basically you guys
I was a student 20 I was saying 20 but I
guess it is 21 years ago you know a lot
different different facilities but it's
really weird to kind of come full circle
and actually present back to you so I'm
super super super thrilled about it I'm
gonna talk about a topic that's near and
dear to my heart and my partners at true
ventures hearts actually about designing
an EQ or emotionally intelligent driven
venture capital firm and I'll talk a lot
about what that means but first I I just
wanted to set a little context on Tom
did that oops
Tom did that earlier but this was I
don't know if Tom if you recognize this
this was the Fortune magazine cover
where the Mayfield so I was a Mayfield
fellow back in 1997 back then was
actually called TVC and then it became
Mayfield Fellows and that summer July I
think of 97 and we couldn't find the
magazine we're looking all over for it
so you couldn't find the picture inside
but we there was a picture of us in this
Fortune magazine the actual Mayfield
Fellows class and it was like this
really huge deal it was kind of a big
launching point for us it's really a pre
Luud of so many amazing things that have
happened with Mayfield Fellows the
program with stvp and one thing I'll say
to you is for me that was my complete
introduction to technology to
entrepreneurship to Silicon Valley it
was really the springboard for my
basically my entire career so I would
say you should consider yourselves very
lucky take advantage of this opportunity
it's a huge deal the relationships I
made back then are still relationships I
have today so the one thing I'll say is
this Ferrari is a really bad image this
is back then they're trying to showcase
how cool Silicon Valley was really
antithetical to everything I'm going to
talk about but that that was the cover
back then just a little bit on true
ventures and I'll get into this topic I
didn't want to do a big commercial on us
but I've been there 10 years the firm
started 13 years ago we've raised our
first fund twelve years ago there's
about 20 of us I'm sorry among our sort
of partner team we founded
close to 20 companies ourselves three of
our partners are actually entrepreneurs
at the same time so it's kind of a very
different kind of mix of people we have
about nine funds under management now
over two billion managed there's a about
a hundred forty companies that are
active across all the funds and about
two hundred sixty founder CEOs that are
active today more importantly you know
close to ten thousand employees across
all the portfolio something we're really
really proud of and one thing we like to
say I'm gonna talk a lot about our
culture but we like to say we like to
start small but we don't think small so
we the strategy has not changed
essentially what we do is we invest a
little bit of money at that early stage
usually one to two to three million
dollars and then we stayed throughout
that company's life but when we start
companies are super raw super early just
really visions and stories right and so
that's where we tend to play and that'll
come into more context as we go so
getting it to the topic a little bit
this is a picture of Doug song I don't
know if you recognize him but Doug song
is the founder and CEO of duo security
so we've been humbled recently by some
of the success we've had you know last
year you may have heard of ring which
sold to Amazon we were the first
investors there for the first investors
in duo security was just sold to Cisco
for over two billion dollars but you
know this is that image of like hey yeah
I did it right
and if you read most of TechCrunch most
of articles they're all great
publications but it's all about the
success right it's all about here's this
next fund that's ready to raised a
bajillion dollars you know here's this
company that's raised twenty thirty
million dollars or actually not even 20
that's small right hundreds of millions
of dollars right so it's all about this
beautiful great success and it's good we
should celebrate that success there's no
question about it but the reality is and
this is what I kind of live every day as
a venture capitalist is this like this
right you know if you look from point A
to point B where a company starts to
where it exits it's up and down and it
is crazy you know there's all kinds of
really tough decisions that happen in
this process around your leadership team
products your burn rate there are at
least there's several crises
along the way I can tell you that right
now and so it's not that sort of simple
journey and that's what I kind of want
to talk to you more about today and I
actually took some time to think through
some of the questions that actually
founders have asked me and talked to me
about over through the years actually
all of our partners some of these
actually happened today I'm not no joke
you know and even in the last week right
so stuff like I want to sell sell my
company I have an illness
I made a big personal mistake I can't
afford to support my family I can't
stand X Y Z board member
our CEO wants to leave we missed the
quarter by a mile
right so and so executive won't scale
I'm not having fun anymore these are
like real conversations that happen
literally all the time and so part of
this job I mean it's it's like
psychology it's therapy right it's and
so you can look at this and say hey
these are a bunch of business issues
right partly a lot of businesses use
these are things that you have to deal
with as you scale a company but the
reality is they're really human issues
right like they affect the whole person
and they affect their families and the
families of all the people that are
around them and their their individual
lives so it's a very human issue and
that's that's where I get to a little
bit around what EQ really is right or
emotional intelligence right so if you
think about it from a venture capital
perspective venture capital is
fundamentally a human business right all
these companies there's people behind
them they're people who build these
products there's people who ship stuff
there's people who start them right and
all the decisions that are made inside
of these companies have real emotional
drivers that no only affect them but
affect their families and all others
around them as I was just mentioning so
you have to think about the whole person
right and so if you can get as a venture
capitalist if you can actually get in
touch with someone's emotional drivers
what's actually driving them emotionally
and you can understand what they're
going through you and them will win at
the end of the day and that doesn't
always necessarily mean monetary success
but you will win because you will
understand each other in a better way
and I'll talk through that one thing I
do want to say is it's not just about
you know being a true leader and saying
hey you know I'm
just here to do whatever you say I'm
gonna support founder whatever you say
I'm gonna do it's actually the opposite
of that it's it's really being having
honest truthful conversations right and
so I'll get into a lot of what it's so
that that's kind of a backdrop of what I
mean a little bit by emotional
intelligence but I want to unpack it a
little further specifically around what
it means for venture capital so I would
say there are two emotions basically a
venture capitalist can drive in an
entrepreneur or project entrepreneur or
even elicit from an entrepreneur and I
think those two things are either fear
or safety at a high level so fear you
know if you project fear onto an
entrepreneur it's pretty dangerous
because you're living in a world of
really imperfect information and so if
they're always looking over their
shoulder afraid or paralyzed right to
make a move to take a step forward to
take a chance right it can be really
really debilitating think of anytime you
have been afraid in your life or had
fear right it's super paralyzing can't
really do anything if you think about it
and we really believe this fear kills
creativity
it kills risk-taking it kills all your
personal growth right it's it's a huge
huge issue right if you think if you
think about safety which is really
having the space to be yourself is what
I really mean by safety it's the exact
opposite right you become more creative
you actually take risks you grow right
think of this school it's safe it's a
good great place to learn right this is
what this school is all about but fears
a big issue right so let's even unpack
that further right so why does a venture
capitalist have fear right does anybody
know what loss aversion is raise your
hand if you know what loss aversion is
have you heard of it it's just a few of
you it's kind of like what it sounds
right it's it's the fear of losing it's
the fee it's it's thinking negatively
always about loss instead of actually
thinking about what is capable what what
can what actually can happen so to break
it down to what a venture capitalist
thinks it's actually the fear of losing
money right and it can happen in a
couple ways right so it can happen right
at the beginning of an investment so
you're making a new investment and
you're kind of like wow like I did you
know this can go wrong that can go wrong
by the way you can
knock yourself out of every single
investment possible as venture capitals
cuz there's always a hundred things
wrong at a really really really early
stage right so it's that fear it's also
the fear of when you've already made an
investment so things aren't going so
well say you put two million dollars in
the company and the company starts doing
pretty well and now you have to put
another five million dollars in the
company does your mind go all the way
back to the two million that happened
before and you say well I already I
think I'm gonna lose that two million
I'm gonna lose this five it's gonna be
seven million or are you thinking well
you know what we're gonna put this money
and we're gonna go win right so it's
it's a real big fear of losing everybody
has it so it's not like you know
nobody's holier than thou right but
everybody has this fear right and it's
not just venture capitalist but it's in
life right so what we try to do a true
and this is how we design this is where
I get to how we designed the firm we
wanted to put EQ at the root of what we
were doing so we would try to do is
design a way to actually lessen loss
aversion right so we could actually
bring safety into the boardroom so that
the entrepreneur could be their best
self right so one of our core tenets at
Tru is to and one of our core
philosophies is that we want to maximize
risk we want to maximize risk on product
we're gonna maximize risk on timing on
market we want to get in early and
basically swing for the fences and by
the way the idea of maximizing risks a
lot of venture capitals won't say it but
you know it's like the third bullet
point that's been in our our slide deck
when we go raise money for 13 years it
hasn't changed we always say we want to
maximize risk but here's the thing we
want to minimize risk on the dollars we
put in and on the people we invest in so
we want to really know these individuals
extremely well
and what I mean by dollars is that we
usually our first investment is
typically you know two and a half
million dollars right that's less than
one half of one percent of our whole
fund so this is gonna sound totally
blasphemous but basically it's okay to
lose it all right we don't want to lose
it but it's actually okay to lose it so
when we walk into a boardroom now we're
not bringing our fear of losing money
because we're not investing a ton of
money to start all right
we're actually saying be your creative
self pivot do this do it do whatever it
takes to build this company right so
that's um that's a big part of that's a
big part of our thinking the other
aspect I would say that we've designed
the firm around is we do not believe in
consensus decision-making so we don't
all have to agree to make an investment
there's no like point system that says
okay you know we got about 35 points and
we're gonna make this investment right
we we actually encourage dissension we
want to disagree right so every deal we
do you know there's a couple people that
are saying hey this is really cool
there's a couple people going like oh my
god like have you thought about this
this this and this that's great right we
want that because if you're all agreeing
on everything we're playing at the
lowest common denominator and not
actually out there
maximizing risk but more importantly
when I walk into a boardroom and I'm
actually talking to an entrepreneur
I'm not worried that hey you know my
other partner over there didn't think
this deal was so good because frankly we
disagree almost on every deal so it's
normal for us right so you don't have to
be right when you first when you make
that first check it's super important
you don't have to be right what we're
trying to do is simply create a process
for maximizing risk if we follow that
process we know six or six funds in that
some stuff is going to work right so
this is again how we design this right
the second thing and this is the
corollary to all of this is that we
really try to have a culture of of no
attribution so this is the is the true
team super proud of our team this is at
least the investment side of the team
nice picture but so venture capital is
kind of a star business right you see
the Midas list and you see everybody
talking about their wins etc it's a
little bit of a star culture and you
know that's that's okay some people
really like that but if you try to
create a culture of no attribution first
of all you can help companies a ton so
what that means is we work as a team we
try not to take credit and say this is
your deal or this is my deal so on terms
of helping companies when we make an
investment yeah there might be
point person but the reality is is you
get the whole team right because there's
so many moments where people can help
right like Oh Malik over there enough
you know ohm he's the pea created Giga
ohm a long time ago ohm is one of the
best storytellers in the world right he
should help you market yourself right
our CFO Jim Stewart who's sitting over
there in the middle he's taken five
companies public he should tell you how
to hire a CFO right Jeff Fein who's
sitting here you know he's one of the
top probably three designers in the
world web designers in the world he
should be telling you is that design
stuff so if I'm not if I'm not feeling
good about incorporating the entire team
into whatever investment I'm making in
just living in a silo that's not good
for the entrepreneur the other thing is
on the failure side if you think about
it so if you have this culture of your
deal versus my deal and this is where
again you can avoid loss aversion right
if if it deals going bad this is what
typically happens right an investments
not going well and someone says hey you
partner this investments not going well
you better fix it right that person
starts getting nervous right they aren't
sure about even making new investments
and then they go into the boardroom and
start talking to the entrepreneur and
they start getting nervous and then a
bring on that same fear and panic right
so if we can create and this is super
hard to do we try to create this culture
of no attribution meaning we don't try
to assign deals to people so that we can
actually again bring safety to the
boardroom and one subtle thing I mean
this is very intentional if you go to
our website for example because a lot of
it is you have to live these actions
right if you go to our website you won't
see what companies each of us are on the
board over what we invest in you'll see
in general what true is invest in but
not buy partner we may be the only
venture firm that's ever done that
there's a couple right but this is these
are subtle things right but that's how
we propagate our culture internally to
again bring safety in the boardroom the
third thing I you know I've been talking
about safety a bunch but this is very
intentional part of it right and you
guys have some of this too for sure but
we have invested a ton of our resources
in building community and you can
actually tell what people care about in
times by where they're actually
investing money
we invest a lot in this right so this is
our this is all our founders and CEOs
that are what we call our last founder
camp
this was back it out in Carmel when we
bring all these guys together so it's a
great picture of them but we have you
know as I said 140 active companies 260
plus founder CEOs in the community and I
like to call it a hyper-connected
community that's a basically a
non-judgmental zone right so whatever
question you have you can ask you will
get an answer probably within 5 minutes
and you will not be judged so you can
absolutely be vulnerable right and talk
about your issues so like for example
this founder camp what you're gonna hold
in another week or so we bring all these
folks together and we don't have outside
speakers we don't call it like a CEO
summit which are great too you bring
this great you know Bill Gates or
whoever in and he's he talks about his
life and what he's done it's amazing we
just have our founders and they just
talk about their problems off the record
right it's not a big ring the bell
rah-rah fest some of that but for the
most part it's actually talking
seriously about what they're going
through right similarly we've invested
really heavily in something called true
forums which is kind of modeled after
YPO founders get together every month
ten of them or so they have a moderator
off the record and they talk about
issues that are affecting them we're
investing in mental health right we put
a lot of our dollars into this because
again it brings huge safety and we
allows them to be their best self which
is a really really big deal in our book
right
so hopefully this stuff is not
completely glossing over your head and
kind of to - up in the sky I mean this
is this is how we have designed the firm
so I thought what I'd do is actually
walk through some very real-life
scenarios and how we how we reacted in
those scenarios right and by the way
this is not black and white these are
there's a lot of shades of grey this is
hard to figure out
I've anonymized all of it so I really
hope I do not get in trouble but but
this but I thought we could bring this
to you so so here's the first scenario
right so this this really happened so a
CEO calls the day of the financing
so when we actually wire the money so
when we invest we do a term sheet we
sign it
usually the lawyers work for a month you
close it and then what happens is
there's actually a day where you wire
the money from your bank account into
their bank account so that's this day
the day of the wire we've wired I think
in this case it was five million dollars
so it's it was about double what we
normally do so it's a big cheque for us
okay and the CEO calls with some bad
news and the CEO says hey I have cancer
right
it's very serious he's not sure how long
he has to live it's devastating he
didn't know he had just been getting
tests in that past week and so you know
on the one hand you're sitting there and
you're like this is horrific like what
do we do so what had you it's material
new information big reason why we
invested was this individual right
we vest behind these people who take us
and basically 75 percent of the reason
we invested was because of that person
but now that person is telling us he's
not gonna be able to work in this
company right and it's a very serious
issue for him and his family so question
is what do you do all right and I'll
give you a few options I'll see what you
guys pick right so one is you sort of
say gracefully hey like you need to go
take care of yourself
we need to take the money back because
you know this is solely different from
what we invest in but you know please
take care of yourself we're so sorry let
go do that the second option is I would
say just give the money and go for it
right and I would say a third option
I'll give you a third out which is I
don't know okay so how many of you would
do a it's probably a third 30u I think
how many of you do it would do be it's a
little more how many you don't know see
okay a bunch of you it's pretty
interesting it's like almost divided
evenly right these are hard things right
so I'll say what we did on the spot we
said take the money it's yours don't
even worry about it
don't think about it go take care of
yourself and your family and the reason
is because if you think about our values
right it's about thinking about the
whole person by the way there were like
15 other people in the company right it
was a moment for everyone
where everybody had to step up including
us and so he said go do what you need to
do we're all gonna step up there's too
many families who are at stake here who
are involved in this let's go make this
happen so we didn't hesitate we gave the
money companies actually doing well and
he's actually doing a lot better we
don't know what the outcomes gonna be
but we've all kind of stepped up and
done it right but as you can see like
it's not none of this stuff is a
no-brainer right as you think about it
so this is an interesting one okay so
the cut so we invested a small amount of
money in a company this is a little
different for us usually we lead around
and then the company pivoted into a
different direction that we felt was
counter to what we believed in so it
became this kind of anonymous chat app
at that time and by the way it was
taking off it was growing like crazy the
founders said hey this is a direction we
want to go the problem was that a
byproduct of it was there was some
bullying going on in it these anonymous
chat apps aren't necessarily the best
places for like high schoolers to hang
out so you know we sat down and said you
know what do we do like we don't really
have a lot of influence here but this is
really kind of counter to our value
system like we don't believe in this
like we want to fund companies that make
impact that's part of one of our core
values so like part of EQ is thinking
about your value system and living your
value system so what we did was we call
the founders up in a very open way we
said look we respect what you're doing
but we don't think this makes sense for
us so what we did was he said you can
have all our stock back for a dollar so
we just sold it all back to him for a
dollar gave it get back which is pretty
crazy you know this stuff could have
been worth millions and millions of
dollars I actually don't even know what
happened but we just said for our sake
for our long-term sake we have to live
by our values right so another
interesting scenario so I have a few
more of these and by the way I have a
hundred if you ever want to sit down but
this one is board member at odds with
the founder and wants their money back
okay so
counterparty risk is a big thing so
counterparty risk means you know you're
in a boardroom there's another person in
the boardroom has other interests and
that's causing friction in terms of
what's going on right so in this case
this is a startup we invested in a new
investor came in didn't like the
direction the company was kind of going
up and down put a lot of money in this
new board member and was sort of
pounding the table and saying I need my
money back I don't even want to have
anything to do with this right
that's a tough situation right this is
an example of loss aversion like direct
the person put a big check in right was
bringing fear into the boardroom right
he he was nervous about his investment
he was starting to get panicky right and
that was then like being reflected onto
the founder who was basically just
nervous at all times all right it's a
really real issue we on the other hand
thought the founder had been making some
steps what was growing was getting
better good product like we wanted to
see it through so what do you do right
so we tried to talk it through that did
not work
this person was pretty adamant about it
so at that point we said well what can
we do to help this person go forward and
so what we said was hey you mister board
member this is gonna be difficult but
why don't you just take your money back
just take it we'll keep our money in you
take yours back we'll figure out how to
go raise some more money which was going
to be difficult having to do that but
we're like let's do it let's give this
entrepreneur a channel so we had that
conversation that's kind of what
happened ultimately it was sort of a
wake up call and the person got off the
board but interestingly as soon as this
person got off the board you could tell
the the founder is sort of there was
like a release valve right they started
just feeling like they could perform
better they could take chances safety
right the company started doing better
and actually ended up with a good
outcome all right so you can see it like
it can paralyze you and in this case we
sort of unlocked that sometimes it
doesn't work often times but this is a
really cool one it's one of my favorite
ones which is a a founder admits that
the idea is not working after spending
most of your money
but has a new idea and wants money that
needs money didn't this really want Lee
so luckily it was a smaller check it was
a seed check so like I said before like
it's okay we can lose money in some of
these situations but in this case you
know the founder had gone through it
what I liked about it was that because
we had a trusting relationship she
talked about earlier that trust piece as
part of EQ he told us like I don't think
this is gonna work right you didn't try
to hide the ball he wasn't afraid he
just said I don't think it's gonna work
but I have this other idea and you know
it's interesting because when we met him
we're like you know that other idea is
actually really good and actually fits
your fits your background extremely well
it's kind of what we wished you did all
along so what we did was we said fine we
lost that money there and we actually
invested in a new company of his so we
put more money into his new company and
that company's actually thriving today
but what I sort of out of this interlude
so we've had 23 repeat founders now in
our history right and a lot of them
actually didn't necessarily succeed the
first time because there's a lot of
factors that are frankly completely out
of your control when you invest all the
time but we've actually believed in the
person so you know sometimes you have to
you can't just form a judgment early on
you have to have that trust so you can
actually talk to each other openly about
it and if you have that sometimes you
can make magic right which is what
happened in this company say if we
didn't have that kind of relationship
right we wouldn't be able to do what we
wanted to do right so make sense all
right the last one's a tough one but the
founder and CEO is not performing as the
company is scaling okay so this is the
person you invested in is the person you
believe in this person you stand behind
but the company is not performing all
right and I talked about a little bit
about this earlier right EQ does not
mean hiding from the hard conversations
it's the exact opposite means going
toward these hard car
right so in this case we sat down with
the founder and we were very open about
it and we said hey look like you've
built an amazing company but going
forward it's not really working right
now right so is like are you feeling the
same thing right and interestingly in
this case the founder knew it - more
often than not the founder or the
individual is feeling the exact same
thing so again it was kind of a release
valve for that person and what we
decided to do was say let's look for a
CEO here you take this picture and we'll
actually look for this person together
and let's see if we can build this
company in a little bit differently
right but these conversations come up
all the time and the best way to handle
it from an EQ perspective is to actually
have trust and be open about it but you
can't do it unless you create that
safety net to start right so so that's
that's that's one of my last scenario
there so if you think about this you
know I've been talking a lot about how
we kind of design true and how we both
affirm the way we did you know the
question is what does it mean you know
for all of you right you're sitting here
like I'm like you know was this mean for
my day-to-day life right and a lot of
you are undergrads as I understand it
when I was sitting in your spot I
probably didn't really appreciate this
the way I do now and I would say you
know hopefully out of this talk the sort
of the number one thing at least you
gain out of it is that EQ matters a lot
you know a lot of you're going to your
classes you want to succeed your
Stanford students you want to get great
grades you want to go do the next job
but EQ is maybe the most important thing
it just really is and your personal life
and your professional life it will
matter a ton the second thing I would
say is is around living your values so
you know have a value system develop a
value system and I would say design your
life or your job or whatever it is to
have these values right like just as
true like for example we consciously
said we're gonna build true
so that we can have these values and it
will it will allow us to be our best
selves in a lot of ways and have these
values that I just described all this
stuff you can't do it unless the firm is
design that way right I would say the
same thing for you guys if you start a
company if your employee at a company if
your manage a team at a company in your
personal life
think about your value system and how
you're going to design your life to
adhere to these values and live these
values right and I try to do that every
day super hard but we try to do it every
day and the other piece the last piece I
would say is don't compromise so you
know I think don't listen to any advice
that basically says you know you can't
have a high EQ and have a great bottom
line I don't believe that at all in fact
I think the two are deeply intertwined
right and and by the way it may not look
that way oftentimes in the short term
but it's absolutely true in the long
term so try to keep the two absolutely
together intertwined together and just
just try not to compromise I know
there's gonna be moments in your life
where you're going to be tested I just
guarantee it
it's super hard but that's what I would
leave you with so that's all I had today
hopefully this gave you a sense of how
we work but hopefully gave you some idea
of sort of how to live your own life
you